bei mir begrüße ich jetzt Gregor Gysi
herr Gysi wie sehr schmerzt dieses
Ergebnis das Schmerz das Ergebnis ist ja
auch desaströs und viele die engagiert
gearbeitet haben sind natürlich dann
auch zu Tiefs pessimistisch und traurig
die muss man jetzt wieder aufbauen wie
wollen sie die denn wieder aufbauen weil
das denke ich ist relativ schwierig bei
fünf Prozent bei der vergangenen
Bundestagswahl 9,2 das ist eine
Verringerung um die Hälfte wie wollen
sie die wieder mobilisieren es ist so es
gibt nach meines Erachtens verschiedene
Ursachen man soll auch nicht gleich am
ersten Abend versuchen das zu
analysieren aber ich würde mal sagen
dass aus Thema haben wir doch
zu spät besetzt das zweite ist dass uns
früher unsere Vielfältigkeit genutzt hat
und das ist jetzt vorbei es gibt ja
unterschiedliche Standpunkte in unserer
Partei und die einwählen uns nicht weil
sie anderen gibt und die anderen wählen
uns nicht weil sie einen gibt also wenn
man da eine klare Richtung hätte wäre
das besser dann hatten absolut recht was
den Afghanistan Krieg betrifft da hätten
wir sogar gewinnen können und unser
chaotisches Abstimmungsverhalten bei dem
Regierungsantrag zum Abzug der
Bundeswehr hat uns glaube ich sehr
geschadet also das wären so die drei
Sachen die mir als erstes einfach nun
waren ja die letzten Bundestag die
letzten Landtagswahlen in den östlichen
Bundesländern Sachsen-Anhalt Brandenburg
Sachsen die waren ja auch schon mit
schlechten Ergebnissen warum hat man
dann anschließend nicht sich hingesetzt
und überlegt warum können wir nicht die
Wähler WählerInnen im Osten wieder mehr
einbinden als Linke also ich hoffe dass
man das überlegt hat wo sie müssen ja
folgendes wissen wir haben inzwischen
sehr viel mehr Mitglieder aus den alten
Bundesländern als aus der neuen das hat
sich geändert und ehemalige
SED-Mitglieder wie ich sind die absolute
Rarität geworden ja die haben eine mehr
darstellt dadurch hat sich natürlich
einiges verändert aber ich glaube dass
sie jetzt auch verstehen werden wie
wichtig das osthema ist und ich bin ja
ganz zufrieden mit den beiden
Landtagswahlen heute wir haben zwar auch
leicht verloren aber das hält sich ja
noch einen Grenzen im Unterschied zum
Bund und auch im Unterschied zu
Brandenburg und Sachsen-Anhalt also sage
ich mal müssen wir mal uns beschäftigen
was es in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern anders
gelaufen was ist auch in Berlin anders
gelaufen da waren sie natürlich in der
Regierung und nicht wie früher wo wir
dann viel verloren haben sondern diesmal
haben sie zumindest kaum verloren das
heißt die Regierungsarbeit wurde schon
einigermaßen gewürdigt aber wie gesagt
nicht zu schnell und nicht in den alten
Fehler verfallen wo nachher a immer
erklärt dass Herr B schuld ist und Herr
B immer erklärt dass er Arsch schuld ist
die selbstkritisch umgehen damit es ist
schon mal eine gute gute Ansatz finde
ich sie haben eben die Afghanistan
Debatte schon an gesprochen es gab
danach wieder viel hin und her der eine
sagte das dann wurde auf Twitter
antwortete Herr neu Herr Lederer möchte
die Partei zerlegen weil er dafür
gestimmt hat und sowas also diese
Vielstimmigkeit innerhalb der Linken das
ist doch das eigentliche Problem oder
genutzt schadet uns jetzt und deshalb
müssen wir uns jetzt mal klar darüber
werden wohin wir wollen damit wir ein
klares Bild für die Leute haben und dann
werden wir bestimmte Wähler
wahrscheinlich verlieren aber andere
werden wir gewinnen und die können wir
dann auch an uns binden also ich werde
wenn ich denn direkt gewählt sein sollte
in Treptow-Köpenick und dadurch
einziehen in den Bundestag werde ich in
unserer
fraktionsversammlung auch dafür
ernsthaft streiten sie können ja
Königsmacher quasi sein falls es jetzt
wirklich unter die fünf Prozent Hürde
geht naja ich hoffe nicht ich bin ja ein
Zweck Optimist und deshalb gehe ich mal
davon aus dass wir noch leicht nach oben
gehen wir werden aber was glauben Sie
denn abschließend noch eine Frage warum
braucht Deutschland die Linke was sind
Themen wo sie sagen das ist doch
eigentlich das was deutsche Wählerinnen
und Wähler gebrauchen könnten aber wir
haben es jetzt nicht erreicht also
erstmal braucht man uns zur Vereinigung
bei der Osten sonst viel zu wenig
Beachtung findet aber zweitens braucht
man uns bei allen Fragen die es es gibt
dringend für die soziale Frage auch die
ökologische Nachhaltigkeit muss in
sozialer Verantwortung geschehen und das
muss unser Schwerpunkt sein und drittens
glaube ich ist die Friedensfrage sehr
wichtig und da sind wir auch sehr
berechenbar im Unterschied zu den
anderen nicht vergessen dieser dieser
chaotische und völlig falsche Krieg in
Afghanistan ist ja von SPD grün Union
und FDP immer gut geheißen und
beschlossen worden nur wir am von Anfang
an gesagt er ist falsch und wir hatten
recht aber dann machen wir eben wieder
den Fehler bei der Abstimmung über den
Regierungsantrag was mich auch ärgert
aber war nicht zu ändern dann warten wir
mal ab wie sich die Zahlen
weiterentwickeln alles Gute und damit
gebe ich zurück ins Wahlstudio